Joe Jonas and sophie Turner are engaged  just love and be loved the 28 year old  singer and the Game of Thrones star took  to social media to share the exciting  news  both posting this shot announcing their  engagement while showing off the 21 year  olds beautiful new diamond ring he  killed Sophie captioned the suite photo  I said yes  while Joe confirmed it in his caption  quote she said yes Sophie and the dnce  frontman have been linked since November  2016 when they were spotted together at  a Kings of Leon concert in the  Netherlands and have kept their  relationship rather private ever since  [Music]  Jonas's brother Nick took to Instagram  to congratulate the happy couple writing  congratulations to my brother and  sister-in-law to be on your engagement  and love you both so much I need to get  accessory  [Music]  you